لكن مشاهدينا ما يقلق واشنطن حقا هو تنام
التعاون الروسي الايراني واذا كانت طهران
وموسكو لا تخفيان تعاونهما فان واشنطن لم
تكف عن ابداء تخوفاتها في اخر مظاهر هذا
التعاون توقيع روسيا لاتفاق يقضي بتمويل
وانشاء خط للسكك الحديديه في ايران ليكون
جزءا من خطط اقامه ممر نقل دولي يربط بين
الشمال والجنوب الرئيس الروسي نفسه اشرف
على هذا التوقيع عبر اتصال مرئي مع الرئيس
الايراني هذا التعاون الايراني الروسي
يشمل ايضا التعاون العسكري الذي يشكل رقما
مهما في هذه المعادله تعاون وتنسيق عسكري
برزان مجددا خلال لقاء جمع قائد البحريه
الايرانيه شهرام ايراني بنظيره الروسي
نيكولايز يومينوف في طهران
دعا خلاله قائد السلاح البحريه الايرانيه
بشكل صريح الى تعزيز التعاون مع روسيا من
جانبه اعرب قائد البحريه الروسيه عن تطلعه
لان تسهم زيارته لطهران في تعميق التعاون
الثنائي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات